how old is scp-106 really is this  ferocious fogey really as ancient as you  think depends on who you think he is if  you think he's actually dr robert  scranton who disappeared into scp-3001  as an adult back in the year 2000 he's  likely between 60 and 80 years old if  you believe he's actually corporal  lawrence who was an adult likely in his  30s during world war 1 he'd currently be  well over a century old and if you're  really spicy and believe he's a holdover  from a whole species of scp-106's who  went into hibernation when his species  went extinct he's likely been alive for  anywhere between 40 000 to 130 000 years  now that's a whole lot of birthday  candles to try and blow out no wishes  granted for this guy this year my god he  really is an old man